that's like if I jacked off and drank my
[__] and had a baby yep that's exactly
like that and a baby Joe came out that
needs to go on the platform
why this happened so why are you not a
scientist
I am
[Music]
hey do you guys remember what happened
in the plot of Jurassic Park yes oh
which one though first one 100 the
embryo I could tell you the whole movie
right now really tell me I kind of
forgot about it uh Island nebula was
made by a crazy old man who took you
know the DNA from a mesquite mosquito
from Amber and that had dinosaur blood
inside of it and then they extracted
that and they use that to create
dinosaurs he made an entire theme park
out of it and then but like like the
Folly of man hubris got in the way and
he pushed it a little bit too far and
Jeff goldblum's tried to warn him and he
says [__] you Jeff goldblums I'm gonna
do it anyway and he and he and he opens
the park because he has Predators [__]
goes Haywire the park wasn't ready for
the stress test of having a [__]
T-Rex and all these [__]
Velociraptors and [__] they lose power
during the rainstorm the Dinos get out
runs amok little kid almost dies gets
electrocuted I don't know how that
worked he [__] gets launched like
water
Rippling T-Rex is chasing your T-Rex
chases the little girl she's got boogers
in her nose they're bubbling up and
stuff and then the um you know the the
protagonists
um the guy and Laura Dern's character
they have romance and we're kind of like
they're really old and that's just kind
of gross I don't really need to see them
kissing or nothing speak for yourself
yeah and then the movie
um ends really abruptly actually like
very very very abruptly like all of a
sudden the T-Rex comes out and then like
helicopters come and everything's like
done can you do the Chris Pratt one
yeah I can do it ready yeah uh how about
how about uh
worst movie ever so what did they do to
make sure the dinosaurs wouldn't
reproduce
um I I fell asleep during that part too
they didn't get that far they actually
said that yeah because then they didn't
want the dinosaurs to be having a bunch
of babies isn't that all males females
all females all the dinosaurs in the
Jurassic Park are females
yeah and uh one of the T-Rex was so mad
it's like my wife went into a certain
time of the month you know but then
remember when Jeff Goldblum goes
life finds a way yes what's he talking
about females becoming males one of them
yeah asexual kind of I mean they don't
really become males but then they like
the fish that turn into hermaphrodite
action ended up being able to produce
fertilized uh basically like eggs wow
where they uh they went to California
and got a sex change
so
um basically that's like the craziest
thing like wow so like even when animals
don't have a mate there's a there's a
slight chance that maybe they can just
create magically a fetus and that fetus
would be almost 100 a clone of the mom
and has no other DNA can't rep can't
reptiles do that this is sci-fi though
right you're not are you saying that
there's until now until now away no no
in nature this exists yeah it does yeah
but this is the first uh known case of a
of that happening with crocodile no way
what kind of crocodile naturally it's
self-fertilized this just happened with
the crocodile a female crocodile that
has had no contact with males for 16
years at the zoo said by the female
crocodile yeah she's a little [__]
but the crocodile pants was pretty bored
and they decided to like make their
whole identity about like maybe a sex
change oh my gosh so we know what
happens now they're pretty bored
one fertilized egg normally yeah it'll
lay eggs and then they're just like you
know omelettes but then one of them
actually had a fetus in it and it
cracked and it was born and it was an
exact 99.9 genetic copy of the mom wow
what the [__] and they said that this
only happens in rare cases where like
um it's going through some kind of
stress of not being able to find me so
something in the body adapts yes and it
actually makes a [__] baby I have
nothing and is it just a reptile trait
because I wonder if humans can do this
um it's been documented in Birds fish
I'll let you know
is the very first kind
this is the very first time a crocodile
did it but yeah Birds fish lizards yeah
Liz I know fish they got a gay ass fish
that's like
[Laughter]
and then when there's no more mail one
of them turns male or when one like the
window ratio it's like oh yeah yeah not
enough dudes and then we'll be like well
some of us can be dudes you know but
that one's still two to tango this one
was itself the DNA has no other
influence crazy that's like if I jacked
off and drank my [__] and had a baby yup
that's exactly like that and a baby Joe
came out that needs to go on the
platform
why this happened so why are you not a
scientist yeah I am so infographic of
Joe just like kids it's like a guy I
want a joke then the actual name for
this is called facultative
parthenogenesis
like manifest the baby because they want
it is so bad it basically was the Virgin
Mary crocodile yeah wow it's like
Priscilla Presley
so could this happen to humans nobody
knows they didn't think it could happen
to Crocs well you just named it Virgin
Mary did it yeah yeah but we know that
wasn't Jesus happened that was a touch
of God baby but Jesus wasn't married
because Mary made a Mary right that's
true Mary made of Jesus Mary made of
Jesus not Mary made of Mary but Mary
supposed to make a Marion well I mean
even then it's like she could let's say
that that did happen with Virgin Mary
then that would mean Jesus is a 99 99.9
match genetically could still be a boy
right I don't think so if it's yeah if
it's like where you're gonna get the Y
chromosome from oh that's true yeah that
could be a double X chromosome from God
you get it from God that doesn't that's
not a thing that's not even it's not a
thing no no what is it that's gone how
dare you white supremacist
um science yeah you sound like I'll take
chromosomes
well if you take it out isn't it kind of
downsy I think that's extra oh it's
extra it's not minus yeah
it's a bonus crumbs I thought it was
called Down syndrome because it's like
you're down one chromosome
it's named after the person down Mr
Downs yeah oh [__] really Robert downsey
Jr yeah
oh have you seen that Meme what no I my
uh I don't think my algorithm shows me
things like that oh really being a
decent human and all yeah yeah my
algorithm is a little funny dude
you got a lot of down syndrome stuff on
your Explorer a lot of down syndrome
bits on your feet yeah you get a lot of
that a little bit I love it it's my
favorite I don't want to blame anybody
but someone that's not in this room
today sends me some stuff that's like
that's corrupt in my algorithm we'll see
Jason Jenny soon
have you seen that one where the Down
Syndrome guy is getting like he's in the
mosque and they're doing some religious
ritual and then he's like holding his
head and then the Down Syndrome guy is
like just chilling getting prayed for
and he just [__] smacks the [__] out
of the guy I was praying for him it was
wonderful wonderful how did everyone
react they just they're laughing oh
that's cool and then they're like
there's another one where like they're
praying like they're doing like they're
like like prayer right and then this
down syndrome boy is like chilling by
the post and he's doing like 007 [__]
and he just goes and he shoots this guy
in the back of the butt with a BB gun
and he goes pop and then he runs away
and needs like yeah oh my God I thought
it was wonderful that's incredible
you got any more
anyone else anyone else got something
um
the kid that is downstairs and he's
going he's walking out with it's like a
pool party and then he has uh two beers
and he gets in the pool oh I saw that
it doesn't have to be relatable just say
it Jason Chang doesn't send me those
things
but yeah that's that's the story they
took that crocodile in captivity when
the crocodile was two years old and so
for 16 years not one male has ever been
around she must be so horny poor girl is
she just like the fugliest [__] like
crocodile ever of all time she might be
no they just never had enough it might
be isolated Kate like there's no at the
zoo or something you look at that Croc
and you're like that thing is ugly ugly
would you want a 99.9 genetic copy of
yourself absolutely enough I would
smother it with my with a pill with
myself yeah it was me it was a direct
copy of me I think I would want to
murder it I think I'd be like okay why
I'd be like here's your job find the
[__] gem so I can relax a little bit
you go find the crypto gems and I'll
[__] I'm gonna chill actually I'm
actually gonna go swimming today
while you work that's what I would you
look like a baby version of Steve yeah I
would love it I would love it
yeah I guess there's it's impossible for
a guy to do this you ever see
multiplicity with Michael Keaton he
clones himself so he can like I don't
know raise his kids and [__] but like he
like does all his jobs or done by him oh
that's the one where like he's like prom
photoing himself on the cover yeah with
like eight times a bunch of times but he
has like a mommy version and the
cleaning version like which is maybe the
same thing some argue and then but like
he he basically takes care of everything
that it would take to raise anything or
do or do any job with himself cloned
that's tight that's great it's like Mr
Mom times eight Mr outsourced let's see
where your head's at yeah I actually I
think that's a good idea yeah that's
actually a good idea you can if you
could split yourself off and get the
[__] that you get like need to get done
done uh interesting so do you have like
eight of you's [__] your wife I think
eight there's 16 feet stepping on my
wife's head
instead of just two a lot of pressure
that's nice that's that'd be I'd
probably come way faster
[Music]